the folks who track holiday spending
believe this year's holiday shopping
season will shatter last year's record
spending the national retail federation
predicts november and december sales
could be up as much as 11 and a half
percent from 2020 that would be over 859
billion with a b dollars here to talk
about all of that and all that revenue
is charisse jones usa today's economic
opportunity reporter cherise good to see
you on this christmas eve good to see
you merry christmas now hold on how are
people spending all this money merry
christmas to you as well when we keep
hearing about inflation and shortages
and all kinds of trouble with shopping
in general well a lot of folks have
extra money because wages went up a
little bit this year and then you also
had the stimulus checks and the child
tax credits so people have a little bit
more money in their pocket they're eager
to get out there and shop but the supply
chain is causing some problems right i
mean some of the things you really want
on your holiday list just weren't there
this year so they had to kind of
improvise a little bit to get everything
on their list
go ahead go ahead well we keep hearing
that people are going to spend an
average a little under a thousand
dollars i think it's 886 dollars i
always wonder where they get that number
from number one
but number two what are they spending
money on
you know it's the usual toys you know
barbie and legos and nerf all those
barbie's still big barbie is still big
she's a perennial but also the
electronic items which cost you know a
little bit more money you know you want
to get your smartphone and your xbox
your nintendo switch so all of those
products are really popular clothing you
know you still want to get your roomba
and your insta pot you know those little
small appliances and so kind of the old
standbys with some of the new tech
gadgets that we're really into as well
now speaking of electronics as we lean
into this digital space for holiday
shopping i can't help but to think about
the brick and mortar stores yeah how do
they keep up with online retailers like
amazon this holiday season well they
really served a purpose this year right
because of the supply chain issues so a
lot of folks would go online look for
what they want that doll or that
playstation and if they found it at a
local store they would head out there
immediately pick it up that way you
don't have to wait on it you're not
paying shipping costs so having that
physical presence really helped and also
if you couldn't find that top gift you
could go and look around on the other
shelf and the other aisle and find an
alternative so it really helps you out
during a difficult shopping year i still
love going to the mall haven't been to
the mall in years but i love a good call
or people what why are you doing that
nate this is the last time i know i was
born i know nate but i'm actually not
here at the moment over here in columbus
circle i haven't seen you walking around
i do i just love going to the mall are
people still going to the mall yeah
especially young people they want to
take your instagram pictures and all of
that and i think this year you really
missed the crowds from before yeah going
through the pandemic and so folks really
wanted to get out there and shop in
person more so this year so feels to
look for after christmas you got
anything in mind i think the electronics
i mean a lot of you said electronics
before yeah because the nintendo
switches xboxes were harder to find this
year and so next year when the inventory
kind of opens up that supply chain is
moving a little bit better you can find
that top gift that you couldn't get
before and maybe even save a few dollars
because there's a lot more available and
not as much of a clamor for it and that
could really help you out as well so
being a parent that last holiday season
i was looking for the gaming system and
i had to go to a secondary market even
third market and met a guy on the side
of the road that was pulling him out of
his trunk
what true story what would you recommend
hello my name is nate berlin there's
online there's brick and mortar on the
side of the road
what would you recommend to parents that
might not get it on the first try online
or in store but are thinking about doing
something else well i think you can also
tell the kid you know that santa's going
to bring it in a few months there have
been some tie ups you know give them the
old school gifts you know the board
games and the puzzles and the legos i
mean they can use their imagination and
not be so reliant on tech oh but wait
hold on teresa it is christmas eve some
people have not bought presents can you
give them one tip on what to buy today
they can put under the tree gift
cards or the drugstore get that gift
card and you can buy whatever you want
next year they work for christmas just
not anniversary gift cards
right
parker doesn't like that one no doubt
about it appreciate you thank you so
much hopefully everybody gets what they
want under the tree